Again, I'll want to use a fun quiz
to get you situated with respect to the concept
of an abstraction. Now remember what I told
you about an abstraction, that it's an interface that
allows us to hide all the details. With that in mind, what I want you to do
Is to think about the objects and the terms
that I've laid out on this panel for you.
And you may have come across many of them and from this set tell me which of
these is not an abstraction. There may be more
than one item in this set that I've shown
you on this panel that may not be an
abstraction and I want you to identify all of
the items that you think is not an abstraction.
The first choice I have is a door knob.
The second choice I have for you is instruction set architecture. The
third choice I have is the number of pins coming out of a chip, like a processor
chip. And the next choice I have for you is a logic gate such as
and gate that does the and function. And the next item I
have for you is a transistor. And the next item I have for you is the
INT data type in a programming language like C. And the last item I have for you
is exact location of base pads in a
baseball field. So these are the choices that I'm
giving you and what I want you to
do is think about these different items. Which you
may have come across for sure in your every
day experience, and tell me which one of these
does not qualify as an abstraction. And as I've said, there
could be more than one that does not qualify as an abstraction.